[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
heute gibt es mal wieder ein leckeres
und einfach offen gericht und da ich
mich nicht entscheiden konnte zwischen
lasagne und bedeckt gibt es heute eine
boutique lasagne oder in lausanne im
blick ich muss mir noch überlegen wie es
heißt ihr könnt ihr mal überlegen so wie
es rezept wird ob ihres lasagne oder
bürger lasagne nennen würde und zwar
habe ich mir gedacht nämlich lasagne
blätter und packt da einfach eine
bereitstellung mit rheinblick gehören
typischerweise
käse spinat lauch oder auch gerne mal
kartoffeln oder hackfleisch ich mein
gott wenn ich jetzt murat fragen wird
weiß natürlich gleich eine hackfleisch
kasan japan ist sie wieder finde ich zu
nah am original und ich nehme jetzt
einfach eine füllung ihr könnt ja auch
ganz gerne eine resteverwertung machen
weil ihr einfach auch gemüse mit
reinpacken könnt was ihr vielleicht nur
im kühlschrank gehabt ich zeige euch mal
meine zutaten und ihr könnt wie gesagt
individuell abwandten und dafür habe ich
jetzt hier lasagne blätter schon
vorbereitet zwei stangen
150 gramm baby spinat oder ganz normale
blattspinat etwas olivenöl
300 gramm milch 4 300 gramm käse etwas
salz und pfeffer 180 gramm frischkäse
petersilie ein bisschen käse zum darüber
reiben da könnte jetzt gouda oder so ein
quatsch krawall käse nehmen und habe ich
noch getrocknete tomaten und das sind
welche die in öl gelegt sind ich muss
auch sagen getrocknete tomaten wenn die
in einem gericht mit dabei sind ich
finde ja so eine fleischige konsistenz
und sind einfach richtig schön würzig
also jetzt bereite ich erstmal die
füllung zu wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
alles rot zu bereiten und wirklich alles
so in die auflaufform schichten oder
wenn ihr sagt immer ein bisschen mehr
geschmack und röstaromen dann macht so
wie ich denn ich werde jetzt das ganze
erstmal in der pfanne anbraten und dann
in den ofen geben beim lauf nämlich
immer so die dunkleren äußeren blätter
weg aber nicht so viel wir wollen jetzt
auch nicht zuviel verschwenden alles was
so dunkel bünde ist ist schon relativ
später auch und auch sein strom geht und
dann nehme ich das weg und schneit dann
erstmal und dann wird er gewaschen weil
der einfach meistens so sandig ist dass
man den gar nicht so richtig sauber
kriegt vorher hatte ich hier einfach
gerne ringe schneiden
ich habe so gefühlt echt schon lange
nicht mehr gekocht ich hatte jetzt schon
viele süße rezepte und immer mal andere
rezepte aber es auch richtig schon
gericht für einfach mittwochs oder
abends gab es schon lange
machen würde mehr ihr könnt aber
schreiben was ihre lieblingsrezepte sind
und dann mache ich das ganz gerne
so offen rezept geht halt immer
[Musik]
am besten der salatschleuder zum
beispiel oder eine große schüssel dann
packe ich da jetzt den lauch rein wasser
rein und dann erst mal drehen und dann
kriegt man so auch aus diesen feinen
schichten dem sand schön raus
[Musik]
ist er vorsichtig drehen
im schleuder zudem sammelt auch schön
raus
dann können wir das hier abgießen
und jetzt richtig trocken schleudern
dann gebe ich jetzt hier olivenöl in
einer pfanne erhitzt die und kann schon
mal den porree anbraten
und stehen spinnenart den hatte ich noch
ein bisschen
zwar baby spinat aber trotzdem da habe
ich gleich einfach
[Musik]
man könnte jetzt in spinat zugeben am
besten nicht alles auf einmal der der
hat jetzt noch viel volumen aber das
fällt jetzt schön in sich zusammen
und dann könnt ihr den einfach mit
anbraten bis sie schön flach ist und
dann reicht es euren prinzip schon
und ich kann ihn da zwischenzeit die
soße zubereiten und
es geht auch echt alles jetzt recht
schnell
habe ich jetzt den hirten käse und
stelle es immer schön wird sich ihr
könnt auch schafskäse verwenden das ist
auch gut da wird jetzt erstmal einmal
nur zerbröselt in eine große schüssel
ich habe erst kurz überlegt alles im
mess becher zu verrühren aber dann
dachte ich so eine große chance
überhaupt ist ein rezept ohne knoblauch
das gibt es eigentlich so gar nicht weil
mir
okay dann halt mal ohne
hier immer mal den spinat für nicht
vergessen und sobald hier
zusammengefallen ist die nächste portion
dazu
dann gebe ich jetzt hier die milch statt
so
die eier
und den frischkäse der macht das ganze
dann schön cremig und
haben einfach mal verrühren
ein bisschen salz und pfeffer gebe ich
dazu aber nicht zu viel weil er schon
der käse recht salzig ist also schön
witzig ist
jetzt kann ich hier noch die
getrockneten tomaten und die petersilie
hacken
und wenn ich jetzt aber den harten stil
und dem bereich immer ganz gerne auf für
suppen oder für smoothies zum beispiel
ihr könnt ihr im kühlschrank lagern oder
auch im gefrierfach dann habt ihr das
immer auf vorrat um ist nicht
wegschmeißen
[Musik]
jetzt hat man noch dass reste von den
tomaten das nämlich auch viel geschmack
drin und dann könnt ihr jetzt einfach
alles vermischen also auch
und spinat
mit ist eine soße alles
[Musik]
und auch die zutaten hier
gut dass ich die große schüssel genau
[Musik]
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr jetzt noch
gewürze dazugeben wie zum beispiel minze
und bohnenkraut und muskatnuss passt
auch perfekt dazu das habe ich jetzt
hier noch mit rein
ich habe hier immer die minze aus dem
garten deswegen ist die manchmal noch
ein bisschen grob und dann muss ich sie
so in der hand noch zerbröseln
beckum chaos kommen auch aus dem garten
immer so so typisch türkisches
geburtsname und kiki chili können auch
noch mit 3 1 gegen zehn ehemalige auch
noch ein
ich habe mich immer schön zu schreiben
chile hat so viel denn
das sind die chilis aus meinem garten
und diesem jahr schon
so und dann könnt ihr euch jetzt eine
auflaufform der offenen form nehmen ich
nehme dir die offene form von passage
und vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch
dran aber wir waren letztes jahr mit
sarah und your song morath in der türkei
in istanbul und haben dort verbrachte
besucht patzer brachte gehört ihr
wirklich zu den drei größten
glasherstellern der welt und jeder von
euch hat auch mit sicherheit ein vater
brachte glas bei sich zu hause die coca
cola gläser sind von dort die mcdonald's
gläser sind von dort im prinzip
eigentlich fast alle gläser die ich
kenne sind von dort also achtet der
gamer drauf wenn ihr unter eurem glas
wartet mal wo habe ich mein klar
wenn ihr unter eurem glas diese zwei
tropfen sieht dann ist es ein pascha
bachsche glas und diese auflaufform ist
auch von denen und zwar sind die aus
borosilikatglas sowie auch mein
messbecher und boris tadic hatte die
eigenschaft dass die sehr hitzebeständig
ist nun auch diese kälte und tippte
schocks aus hält also ihr könnt zum
beispiel dieses gericht hier vorbereiten
in der glas form und dann wirklich
einfrieren und eingefroren direkt in den
heißen ofen geben und das schafft eben
nicht jedes glas walid das andere glas
einfach zerspringen würde und sie sind
auch chemikalien fest säure fest
spülmaschinengeeignet mikrowellen
geeignet als es eigentlich so das
hochwertigste glashaus es gibt und bei
denen ist sogar noch das besondere
vielleicht habt ihr das auch noch nicht
gesehen dass so ein ofen form die
wirklich komplett rechteckig ist also
dass auch wirklich zum beispiel lasagne
platten perfekt rein passen und man sind
nicht in der ecke verbrechen muss genau
oder mal ein tiramisu oder haben auch
immer schönes stückchen und ich nehme
die kleine form genau so mache ich das
und
da gebe ich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
olivenöl rein
so an den boden
auf so lege ich jetzt hier in lausanne
ihre platten
und dann wird es hier einfach rein
geschichte
ich habe jetzt hier auch genug
flüssigkeit drin so dass die lasagne
platten eben schön weich werden können
und ich denke ich mache jetzt zwei nudel
oder zwei bis drei minuten platten
schichten rhein und die letzte schicht
schließlich aber mit der sauce ab damit
sie an der oberfläche einfach schön das
gemüse mit dabei habe
das erinnert dann auch so ein bisschen
an souverän also im türkischen gibt es
auch einen blick was auch mit nudelteig
gemacht wird und da werden aber diese
ausgerollten nudel blätter erstmal
blanchiert und kommen dann in die form
aber ich muss sagen gerade so fertige
lasagne platten die muss man ja mal ist
gar nicht vorher abkochen
[Musik]
und teils noch ein bisschen käse drauf
ich muss sagen so für auf bilder und
wird zum anrichten finde ich es immer
schön wenn wir mit der sauce schicht ab
schließt aber für den geschmack wenn ich
so auch immer gut war mit lasagne
platten ab schließt aber da muss noch
mal ein bisschen was cremiges drauf und
käse und dann hat man eine schöne käse
sich am ende aber ich mach das jetzt so
ich will jetzt keine trockene
mittelschicht drauf sondern eine schöne
bunte
gemüse schicht
und so könnt ihr das das dass er so kann
die das gericht jetzt auch gut
vorbereiten und dann in den kühlschrank
stellen und dann wenn ihr abendessen
wollte oder mittagessen wollt einfach
schön im ofen fertig da das ist echt gut
auch so zum vorbereiten vor allem wenn
ihr berufstätigkeit oder einfach keine
zeit habt dann könnt ihr das am abend
vorher zubereitet schön abdecken und den
kühlschrank stellen oder einfach mal
morgens zu bereiten für den abend da
muss man nicht immer abends noch
darstellen also so kann man sich das
echt ganz gut einteilen perfekt ich habe
die küche auf während das gericht in den
ofen kommt und dann wird gleich probiert
[Musik]
jetzt ist das offen gericht fertig das
wird bei utah vor wären
hallo ich stehe gerne lasagne und hatte
strabag gegessen nein ich glaube ich
noch gar kein berliner wohnung dann ist
das ja sozusagen den premieren ich bin
mit türkische gerichte nicht so da
müssen wir mehr zur bereit ja also ich
bin heute richtig richtig froh dass man
jetzt mal wieder was heißt sagte
letzte war echt seien sie also selbst
das stimmt
okay das war richtig luft of gaia
das erste stück
[Musik]
das gehört auch zu dir aber das
bestehende haus ist gut mehr papiere
baufirma
richtig lecker und
vor allen dingen so richtig gesund
und später in morath gegen hertha da
hat er
richtig gut hat so richtig
so ein burgic geschmack aber es ist
schön diese weiche nudel platten also
echt gut und cremig vor allem richtig
cremig
sehr gut also dieses rezept wann hat auf
jeden fall muss ich sagen er meine
lieblings offen gerichte fertig liegen
vor allerdings ist ganz tolle daran
finden die wirklich dass man so gut
vorbereitet ja das ist für mich so als
berufstätige
familie mama noch mal so richtig warm
und vorteile hat kann ja das kann man
abends noch geschwind vorbereiter und
dann kam als echten der backofen
schieben wäre es richtig gut ja ich
glaub ich mache davon mal noch ein paar
weitere abwandlungen wenn ihr wollt dann
können wir jetzt das neue die neue
rezept rasante berg- oder bürger lasagne
einfach neu einführen und dann kann man
verschiedene kombinationen manchmal
keine auschlagsspiel naht und sagen
alles was man so gerne hat also falls
ihr das rezept wünsche oder sogar
anregungen ideen habt könnt ihr sie
gerne in die kommentare schreiben und
dann probieren wir uns da einfach durch
hier hatte oder einfach was der
kühlschrank gegen utah das rezept wasser
ich empfohlen charakter kühlschrank mit
erbsen und soja auch dass jede höhle
wenn es ganz schnell hier muss man kein
seil und auch für gemüse zu schnippeln
stimmt konkreter termin ist nun alles
stimmt also probiert gerne aus und haben
viel spaß dabei das rezept findet ihr
wie immer in meiner app oder auf meinem
blog und jetzt dürft ihr gerne noch auf
instagram vorbeischauen denn auf
instagram gibt es ein richtig großes
gewinnspiel das zeige ich euch jetzt mal
noch heute hier seht ihr ein großes
paket von peshawar ich habe hier unter
anderem auch die offenen formen die bord
schon vorne mit dabei aber nicht nur das
hier sind auch am vorratsdosen jetzt ein
türkisches kann uns nicht mit dabei mit
entwicklern von kaká brachte die mess
becher hier die gläser oder zum beispiel
auch diese partie verlieren wo ihr
kleine törtchen kuchen und gebäck
verstauen können und wenn ihr dieses
große set gewinnen wollt dann schaut
doch einfach mal auf meinem instagram
account vorbei dort ist alles ganz genau
beschrieben ich drücke euch eine ganz
feste die daumen und wir sehen uns
wieder beim nächsten mal
[Musik]